[Music]
it is about creating, through the
legislative proposal, an
integrated system of control of the
external borders of the European Union, what it
is about is eliminating the
passport stamping system in the
consequences, obviously it is more agility
at the entrance  for visitors from a
third country because their data is
stored in the system and the next
time they enter they will not need to suffer
long queues or specific controls
because their data will already be collected in
the system. What it is about is
avoiding that when people  who have
entered illegally
exhaust their period of stay in the
European Union' and remain in the
integrated border control system can
detect these problems to avoid the
illegal or illegal stay of the asset
basically the use of
facial recognition and four fingerprints in
addition  of
alphanumeric data to be integrated into the
system to prevent
repeated falsification of documents  To travel,
one of the modalities is that state
security forces and bodies can access
and from the crossing of
data and information that
early warnings can be
derived or consequences can be derived that facilitate or
make impossible events such as the one that
occurred in the  berlin christmas market
where a terrorist attacks and later it
was determined that this terrorist
had used 15
different identities with the entry and
exit system this will be impossible or very
difficult
[Music]